je suis sûre ça vous est déjà arrivé au
moins une fois dans votre vie de
trébucher et de tout faire pour ne pas
tomber chez nous en guadeloupe on n
paroles bienveillantes
quand ça arrive by getty mais pas tomber
vous savez il m'a fallu beaucoup de
temps énormément de temps 25 ans tous
faut comprendre la puissance du mot big
heat et répété avec moi bigidi non c'est
pas bon bigby c'est un mot magique parce
qu'il chante dans la bouche
vous l'avez senti c'est une musique
c'est une musique au corps ou à le faire
avec la mère bigoudis
encore buggy des sarts aison dans la
tête ça danse dans les corps ça fait
surtout danser les obstacles invisible
sa déboulonne les esprits ça impacte les
que ça ravive les âmes
je crois que tout comme moi ça vous est
déjà arrivé de rencontrer un personnage
au coin d'une rue comme albert heijn de
bad la sauce qui titube part s'ils
trébuchent par là tout comme à l'image
du danseur de gros cas pour ceux qui ne
savent pas le gros casse est une danse
la danse dits traditionnels de la
guadeloupe ourdan seul un peu dans cet
espace qu'on appelle la soirée lire aux
où le danseur il rentre quand il veut et
le dialogue comme moi avec vous entre le
tanbouyé et d'huile et on pourrait dire
que le danseur de coca particulièrement
le danseur de les roses et à l'image de
cet homme saoul mais si on s'attarde un
instant sur cette danse mais surtout
fermons les yeux imaginons que nous
sommes un étranger qu'on arrive dans ce
pays on tombe dans une soirée les roses
en voir
on va se dire mais c'est quoi ça c'est
des structures et désordonnée ça n'a pas
de sens c'est inéligible pour lui et je
le comprends mais c'est justement ce qui
me fascinait dans la danse gros cas
c'est de voir ce danseur qui brusquement
dans cette rapidité s'arrête dans un
silence habité et puis sans raison il
repart dans une frénésie folle pour
s'arrêter dans une lenteur apparente ils
changent d'énergie il peut être dur ou
complètement les jo à la dérive j'étais
prouver que vous savez intuitivement mon
petit coeur me disais que cette danse en
désordre en apparence devait avoir un
sens beaucoup plus profond que ça
un peu comme ti malo quand je suis allé
chercher il avait rien pas d'ouvragé pas
de recherche aucun écrit scientifique
rails aucune antériorité
il fallait que je prenne la décision de
suivre mon instinct et de regarder ce
corps dansant juste en observation et de
l'étudier pendant plus de quinze ans
seuls à l'observer à le décrypter pour
comprendre parce que j'étais convaincu
non seulement que cette dent cela
voulait dire quelque chose parce que je
vous rappelle
parce qu'on a trop tendance à enfermer
la danse dans son objet premier un objet
artistique faut le plaisir des sens des
yeux mais la danse quand un corps danse
dans une société
cette langage intelligible
pour dire la paroles inaudibles des
forces cachées deux peuples donc j'ai
pris le temps d'étudier les muscles les
os les articulations qu'est ce qui bouge
à quel moment à quel endroit pourquoi
j'ai pris 15 ans pour mettre une
taxinomie en place que je nomme technica
mais comme tout processus de recherche
vous savez il ya des moments très
difficiles où on n'a pas de réponse
il ya une phase et pis il fallait que je
nomme parce que il n'y a pas de non ça
n'existe pas et souvent la caraïbe
n'existe pas parce qu'elle n'est pas
nommé
sinon là mais dans quelque chose de
global multi que réalisme diversité
métissage et on a fini donc il fallait
que je trouve des noms pour nommer les
packs je trouvais les exercices et là je
me suis rappelé de big easy mais pas
tomber et je trouvais que le mot bigidi
juste le mobiliser traduisait
parfaitement la gestique que je voyais
dans le che le danseur de les roses est
toujours en suivant mon coeur d'anciens
que ça qui m'a fait avancer pas à pas
c'est de suivre mon coeur mon instinct
et bijoux comme ça comme un déclic je me
suis mise parce que heureusement pour
moi aussi je connais la grande anse
je me suis mise à faire un élément
comparative entre la danse dite savante
et la danse rocha et sur le plan
philosophique vous savez sur le plan
symbolique
lorsqu un danseur de classiques lorsque
le corps touche le sol savez dans des
mouvements très léger touche le sol
c'est la symbolique de la mort mais
lorsque je regardais mon fameux danseurs
de les roses je le voyais trébuché à la
limite de tomber mais comme par miracle
il ne tombe jamais ils ne touchent
jamais le sort jeudi mais c'est la
symbolique de la vie ça veut dire un peu
il est en déséquilibre plus est une
adaptation permanente quand j'observais
ce corps dans son jeu me rendais compte
il ne tombe jamais pourquoi parce qu'il
ya un miracle c'est le phénomène de la
reprise parce que le danseur il peut se
permettre d'être dans n'importe quel
sens chaotique et puis comme par magie
pas d'avs un parent d'un parpaing pas
d'un pin pad un cet instant t c'est le
point ultime de l' équilibre
donc on peut se permettre d'être
chaotique parce qu'on sait qu'on va
retomber sur ses pieds
le big easy mais pas tomber prenait un
sens complètement différent avec une
épaisseur nouvelle pour moi
et puis un jour je me suis dit mais
pourquoi c'est en guadeloupe que le
corps est aussi en déséquilibre comme ça
et si par hasard le bigdil dubroca
n'était pas une parfaite réplique du
pays guadeloupe
ce que je regarde bien on est dans un
désordre permanent
notre rapport au temps notre rapport aux
êtres notre rapport aux choses
notre rapport de la construction même
des shows dans l'édification c'est dans
un principe très simple la rupture de la
gia
on est dans une ellipse continuelle dans
une discontinuité continuelle on
commence ça commence bien
si ça s'arrête
comme par miracle tout retombe tout
revient normalement je suis sûr que vous
savez de quoi je parle
et après je me suis dit mais cette
stabilité du corps parce que ce qui
techniquement fait la stabilité de la
danse brocas ses dettes dans des appuis
et c'est d'être sur les talons et de ne
jamais tomber
on a l'impression que le danseur de gros
qu'à se déjoue du déséquilibre et se
joue de l' équilibre
j'ai vraiment les teams conviction que
la guadeloupe est en train de dire au
monde qui est nouvelle façon
d'appréhender l'equilibre c'est le
déséquilibre ça c'est extraordinaire
parce que finalement la guadeloupe à des
factures qui viennent nourrir cette
instabilité d'abord notre avènement
monde la colonisation ils savent à 7 ko
humain et je crois que le corps a
inventé une danse ça danse pour
réinventer son humanité il a dû être en
des études parce que l' esclavage a été
un déséquilibre il a dû s'adapter
meilleur si l'espace
tout comme le danseur de coca qui
dansent tout seul dans ce pays dans cet
archipel
lille est 100 pays daisy la death un
pays
marie galante saint pé i terre-de-haut
saint pé i ter de basse un pays meilleur
si les facteurs de la nature tout vient
de l'imprévisible de cyclone le 6 le
volcan les raz-de-marée
c'est comme si les voyous paix avait
inconsciemment intégrés qu'ils vivent
dans un espace imprévisible donc à la
limite c'est normal que lorsque je
faisais mes cours de technique cas en
guadeloupe que naturellement en soit
dans le déséquilibre je me suis dit
ce serait intéressant de vérifier le
mobility sur des corps étrangers nous
quand j'allais à l'étranger je me
retrouve avec des japonais des italiens
des américains des africains des
caribéens et je leur disais de danse et
la musicalité du mo by getty s'en
expliquer qu'est ce que ça veut dire en
créole n'est que ça vient du gotha
bigoudis et j'étais à chaque fois
impressionné de voir que ces danseurs
être congé apps complètement absent de
la culture ko produisait 2010 je me suis
mais c'est pas seulement un mot magique
c'est un mot qui révèle une inscription
millénaire qui appartient à l'humanité
parce qu'en fait le monde dit i les
voies loupé ok mais il est universel
parce que tout humain a connu un
déséquilibre dans sa vie rien aucun
humain sur cette terre sauf peut-être
celui qu'est voir qui entend les
couleurs il ya aucun humain qui n'a pas
connu une rupture mais ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant avec la guadeloupe et le
rocha est peut-être ce que nous pouvons
apporter au reste de l'humanité parce
que tout humain le big easy apprend que
nous devons accepter le prévu et faire
corps avec nous devons simplement nous
adapter ne jamais faillir nous avons le
doigt de trébucher nous avons le droit
de flancher
nous n'avons pas le droit de tomber
big easy j'ai pas entendu
big easy mais pas tomber parce que
lorsqu'on regarde le monde les dom
géopolitique son hôte sont déplacés les
grandes orientations politiques et
culturelles sont incertaines et surtout
ce qui me fascine c'est que la nature
l'imprévisibilité de la nature des
grands territoires
vous trouvez pas que ça ressemble de
plus en plus à nos cycles longs tempête
la balle à la seule chose c'est que nous
pouvons leur rappeler les mystères de
l'improbable et fredonner toute la
puissance de l'être humain en dix ans
ayez confiance vous avez les ressources
vous avez toutes les stratégies de la
rue je pense que lorsqu'on le regarde
aux danseurs de roccat qu'est ce qu'il
fait il esquive quand il s'arrête c'est
comme la vie on attend le secon parce
que c'est possible on accélère et si on
est en déséquilibre et pendant c'est pas
grave même si on avance de banques de
manière bancale
on avance quand même la suprématie de
l'equilibre cette verticalité parfaite
mais lorsqu'on tombe on est mort il vaut
mieux être avancée sur sable mouvant
être toujours dans une dynamique de
rebondissements et j'ai envie de dire
simplement que le big easy de la danse
au cas du danseur de l'es2 les roses est
peut-être la solution créative pour
affronter les obstacles du 21e siècle